well uh congratulations on fire country
first off I know this is a special
project to you because not only do you
star in it but you co-wrote you help
produce why is this show so special to
you
um you know I'm I'm from a small town in
northern California
where you know my community has been
affected by a lot of the parties in the
past few years have been going on and
you know where I grew up a lot of my a
lot of my best friends and guys I grew
up with work for this department worked
for you know a lot of different fire
stations and you know do these jobs in
real life a lot of the jobs I think
maybe almost all the jobs that we depict
on the show and you know I felt like it
was a an important and timely you know
moment to highlight these people for the
heroes that they are and you know it's a
firefighting world that we haven't seen
on television for sure
um
you know visually and and just how you
fight fire you know and these Wildland
fires and
and it's also you know a lot of it is
also sort of inspired by this Tiny Town
that I grew up in and
you know what it's like growing up and
living in a town of a thousand people
um where everybody knows everybody every
everybody's sort of connected some way
or another well I love that message and
this sounds like a really important role
that you're taking on but speaking of
roles to me you are always Seth from The
Pacifier one of my favorite movies of
all time but you've done so many
different things in your career do you
have a favorite role of all time or even
just kind of a moment or something that
just you know you hold close to Heart
um man all like honestly all of them I
hold close to my heart just because
they've all been such
amazing learning experiences for me just
like not only as an actor but as as a
person
um and I've been fortunate to be
surrounded by
some really amazing people that have
taught me so many things
um
The Pacifier was probably one of the
most fun experiences I've ever had you
know and I was a young I was 15 and
um like it was just all about fun back
then it was just you know
there was nothing work about about it
um but I think you know I
this one to me is obviously very special
and very personal
I I'm very excited for people to see
this show because you know I'm I'm not
only
excited about Bodhi as a character I'm
really excited for the audience to get
to meet a lot of these characters in the
show Max congratulations on everything
you're starting in multiple shows you
have a beautiful family you can give a
shout out to your in-laws here in
Henderson that's right we can't wait to
see the show and again congratulations
and I'm excited to to see where it goes
from here thank you so much thank you so
much and uh yeah the in-laws they're
watching hopefully you guys are I'm sure
you are but uh yeah go Vegas